Let's look at the solution to our disk access time quiz. We can ignore queuing,
so our read of a randomly chosen byte begins by seeking there.
The head assembly is at one end of the disk. A randomly chosen
byte will be at the cylinder where we are, or 999 cylinders
away, or anywhere in between with equal probability.
So on average, we will be seeking 500 cylinders away, times 10 microseconds per
cylinder. So our seek will take us five milliseconds. At that point, our head
is in a random place on the correct track. Now we need to wait for the
beginning of the correct sector to get under the head. And just like
when we were doing the seek, the rotational latency will
be on average, half of a rotation. Sometimes we will be lucky
and land just at the very beginning of the sector we want. Sometimes we
will be unlucky and land just past the beginning
of the sector we want. So, we will not
be able to read that sector, even though we
are technically right above the data we want to read.
We will have to wait for the beginning of the sector to get back which is
a whole rotation. So, on average, we will
be having half a rotation. Each rotation is
a hundredth of a second or 10 milliseconds.
So we end up adding another five milliseconds
to our read time. Next, we need to
read our sector. There are ten sectors per track.
So the read will take 1 10th of a
rotation, which will be one millisecond because we already determined
that a rotation will be ten milliseconds. So in total,
it will take 11 milliseconds to complete a disk access.